Miami Herald investigative reporter
Julie Brown that's Julie K Brown if you
encounter it in print spent more than
two years looking into the Jeffrey
Epstein case and she published a series
of articles on his secret plea deal
Brown identified eighty of Epstein's
alleged victims and spoke with about a
dozen of them Julie good morning on the
subject of those victims you've spoken
to them you probably know them as well
as anybody at this point how are they
reacting this morning well I think
they're in shock first of all I you know
they were the first people that I called
as soon as I had heard my first thought
I've stayed in close touch with them
this whole case and the fact that he was
arrested was a has been a rollercoaster
for them to say the least they've been
trying to find justice on this case for
a very long time so he beat the system
in 2008 with this kind of easy sentence
did he beat it again by taking his own
life well they think so they think that
it's another example of how our criminal
justice system is not only broken but it
it seems to favor wealthy people who
somehow seem to always be able to get
away with things that regular people
don't have those advantages I'm curious
about the victims I was talking to Oprah
last night who is a victim of sexual
abuse herself and I said what more do
victims want the guy is now dead there's
nothing more that can happen and she
said this had happened to you or your
daughter you would not be feeling that
way can you and I had to think about
that for a second you know you're right
can you understand why they still feel
they were deprived yes because they've
been fighting this for a decade and
remember when this happened back in you
know 2006 2007 these now they're women
but they were teenagers and they were
treated like they were prostitutes they
were treated like they were not credible
you know because they would you know
these Warriors hired private
investigators that you know made their
lives really miserable discredit them
followed their families ran one of their
fathers off the road you know what can
happen now which might have happened is
the kind of dr. nasir moment with USA
Gymnastics where the victims can
confront the victimizer one after
another Julie the US attorney Jeffrey
Berman has made a point of saying the
investigation will continue
where does this case go now well they're
going to look at his accomplices our
so-called alleged accomplices there was
a lot of information as you know that
was released just on Friday yes about
how this operation now is sort of
released in a very strange way because
it wasn't really in sequence but because
I studied all the other documents I
could kind of piece it together a little
bit but it sort of is the framework for
a real sex trafficking operation and now
we know that they're not only just
looking at this at the human trafficking
part of it they're also looking at the
money trail you know and they're looking
at where his money is how he got his
money and hoping that that will lead
them also down another path to finding
who helped him if you were one of his
accomplices at this point would you be
more nervous now that he is dead well
yeah yes I think so because mr. Behrman
is gonna have to start looking at other
people not that he wasn't before but
he's going to probably make a couple of
these other people do the centerpiece of
his case now he killed himself allegedly
after the release of some very damning
documents about him was there anything
in those documents that surprised you I
think some of the names you know we knew
some of those names they had been out
there before because the police
investigation had uncovered a lot of
message pads and you know we also know
he had a epstein had a black book with a
lot of famous people's names on them but
this was really their names in
particular that surprised you well I
think anytime you have someone as
powerful powerful as George Mitchell
for example former senator and Senate
Minority Leader and and Bill Richardson
the governor of New Mexico I think any
time with both of whom by the way all of
these people have denied that they have
not been charged and they have not been
charged and all of them have vigorously
denied that they were involved but you
know when you have a couple of different
depositions and you have that this woman
describing what happened and how it
happened to some degree where it
happened
I'm sure that that's something that
prosecutors are gonna look ok there are
more there are more documents to be
released Julie correct that's correct
you think more people will come forward
it's hard to say it depends on what they
find with the suicide you know at first
I thought that suicide do you believe
that it wasn't suicide there are a lot
of questions about that as well like you
know is he set up to commit suicide or
did he actually take his life a lot of
questions about and the timing of it
what what is your take on it when you
first heard it what was your take well I
thought he probably committed suicide
but then again I you know I covered
Florida prisons for a very long time and
I know the way things work in prisons
and it's very easy to set something up -
I'm not trying to fuel a conspiracy
theory here at all but it is very easy
to set something up to look like a
suicide I'm not saying that happened but
I mean you know I think we have to wait
for the authorities to do their
investigation first well all right Julie
brown thank you very good to have you at
the table